على مجمع الشفاء الطبي مبنى التنميه وهذه
اثار دماء النازحين في داخل المجمع بعد
الاستهداف المباشر للنازحين في داخل مجمع
الشفاء الطبي هذا
احد الماوي
مقصوفه كانت هنا اماكن بيات العائلات
وجلوس
العائلات قوات
الاحتلال خلال ساعات الليل قصفت
هذا
المكان الان محاوله انتشال الشهداء
المستمره من داخل مجمع الشفاء الطبي اللي
صار احنا قاعدين فوق فهمت كيف سعنا دبه
هان نزلنا لقينا سوين ه بعيط وعدناهم رحنا
نجيب الشيلات ضربوا الناس هذول هذا مجرمين
اليهود ايش اللي بدهم منا اطفالنا نسائنا
بعيطه وين وين مجتمع الدوله وين حقوق
الانسان بكفي ع الظلم طلع المجازر مش حرام
نحن نتحدث عن استهداف طبعا
مباشر ل مجمع الشفاء الطبي مبنى التنميه
بالتحديد في الجهه الغربيه للمجمع شباب
على الثلاجات يا شباب على
الثلاجات صار قذايف هدول كانوا شاردين
وصار ضرب عليهم قذايف
فاستشهدوا سبع شهداء وعندك عشرات الاصابات
وما قدرناش نجيب الجرحى
واستشهدوا هذه طبعا اشلاء المتناثره في كل
مكان يعني وفق شهود الاعيان ووفق ما تحدثت
فيه العائلات هذه
عائله من المتواجدين بجوار هذا
المشفى يستمر القصف الاسرائيلي وتستمر
محاولات انتشال جثامين الشهداء في حين ان
هذه المناطق تتعرض لاشتباكات عنيفه
واشتباكات
متواصله جرائم متواصله وقصف مستمر هذه
اثار الجريمه التي ارتكبتها قوات الاحتلال
بحق العائلات النازحه في داخل مستشفى
الشفاء الطبي التي ادت الى ارتقاء سبعه
شهادات قصف ومجازر لا تتوقف بحق اهالي
المناطق الغربيه مدينه غزه اسماعيل الغول
الجزيره مدينه غزه